snoop dogg and eminem reunite for an out
of this world performance at the 2022
vmas
i feel like
every time i palm trees just like that
the song from the d to the lbc me and uh
marshall mathis we collaborated on a
record that we wanted to do for many
years and we finally put it together and
did an amazing video and the video got
nominated and then mtv wanted us to
perform ahead of the show snoop dish to
et how the two would deliver their
latest collab from the d2 the lbc their
first in 20 years we'll be actually
performing
in a different world but actually there
in the metaverse yeah first time ever
you think you slacked for this dude
snoop dogg and eminem begin the track
lounging on a couch with snoop seemingly
smoking a cartoonishly big joint soon
after they're transported into another
universe where they become animated
versions of themselves
yo snoop
is that
yo what the man is the size of my hand
dog the performance ends with the two
back on stage waking up from their
imaginary trip
yo slim
wake up whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa wait
what just happened
this marks the first time either artist
has hit the vma stage in more than a
decade and with the show like that it's
no surprise eminem and snoop received a
standing ovation
[Music]